tonight on Brian Ross investigates
new developments in the case of former
FBI agent Robert Levinson kidnapped in
Iran 12 years ago and still missing
please help me at home with a new reward
of 25 million dollars his family now
says there's reason for hope
plus the spy games I don't dispute when
the same watchdog group which caught a
spy trying to infiltrate their operation
out with a new report and how operators
used whatsapp to track hundreds of human
rights workers and journalists here is
an industry valued in the billions it
spends every day trying to find ways to
access our mobile phones and our
shoutout for the man behind the scenes
who quietly made possible a team of
reporters documenting the plight of
Americans in Appalachia do you still
drink your tap water or is this solely
what you drink it's hard to find out
just how important a force he was in
Appalachia from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigators good evening and welcome
tonight new developments in the mystery
of what happened to an American last
seen alive in Iran some 12 years ago
former FBI agent Robert Levinson who was
quietly working for the CIA when he
disappeared as his family prepares to
sue Iran in u.s. federal court next
month the Iranian government this week
for the first time seemed to acknowledge
there was an ongoing case involving
Levinson a statement that offered new
hope that Levinson might still be alive
only later to have the government say
its comments were being misinterpreted
still as we are about to hear his family
believes there is much reason for hope
he went missing in Iran on March 9th
2007 last seen alive on the Iranian
island of Kish three years later his
family received this distressing video
proof of life with Levinson pleading for
help
it's government to answer the requests
of the group that has held me for three
and a half years and please help me at
home since then his family has waged a
relentless campaign to seek any
information about the former FBI agent
my name is David Levinson and I'm
speaking on behalf of my mother
Christine Levinson and my entire family
I am making a plea to the people that
are holding my father my mother has
received your messages please tell us
your demands so we can work together to
bring my father home safely Iranian
officials have repeatedly denied knowing
anything about Levinson whereabouts but
this weekend Turin officials
acknowledged for the first time there is
an ongoing case involving Levinson later
revising the statement to say it was a
missing persons case in Washington the
State Department has now upped a reward
offer for information on Levinson 225
million dollars and President Trump was
quick to offer his encouragement for
Iran to do something if Iran is able to
turn over to the u.s. kidnapped former
FBI agent Robert a Levinson who has been
missing in Iran for 12 years it would be
a very positive step the president
tweeted and were joined now by Bob
Levinson son Dan who joins us from Skype
overseas and here in the studio by Barry
buyer the Pulitzer Prize winning
journalist who chronicled the saiga of
Lovington in the book missing man dan
let me start with you what the latest
you have on the status of your father
well as you noted the Iranian government
responded to the UN working group we
have been working with and they said it
was an ongoing case and specifically
they said that it was in the
Revolutionary Court and to our
understanding that is the site port
where its criminal cases espionage cases
similar to the ones that they have been
targeting with a
Iranian Americans who have been held
there as well so for us this is a
significant development in acknowledges
that he's been over there and that he's
been kidnapped well there really was
never any doubt that he was there but
the fact they're now saying that this
was a missing person case not an ongoing
prosecution is that frozen cold water on
your hopes it hasn't as I said that the
Revolutionary Court is a very specific
Court and that from what our lawyers
told us that there are no missing
persons cases in that country and I
would it would be hard to believe that
in a security state such as Iran and on
a small island of Kish which my mother
and I visited that there could be any
source of missing persons on that in
that country Barry Maher let me ask you
what do you make of this development you
know I agree with Danone that there
certainly aren't missing persons in Iran
this is an autocratic government that
knows where everyone is and I'm sure
they know exactly what happened to Bob
Levinson where Bob Levinson was kept and
hopefully where he's still being kept
I don't know personally how to interpret
this sort of cryptic one-line sentence
that appears in the report other than to
say that I hope there is someone out
there that can shed more light on this
case because Dan and his family have
been suffering for these past 12 years
and as a practical matter do you think
there is some hope well there's always
hope you know the thing that is
concerning is that for 12 well for now I
guess eight years since the videotapes
and the photographs have arrived we have
not received any new information that
doesn't mean that Bob is not still alive
but it was what it suggests to me is
that there is a very tightly knit group
that has knowledge about his fate and
his whereabouts and hopefully 12 20
million dollars will be sufficient for
one member of that group to realize that
telling the family telling the US
government what happened to Bob is
worth the risk Dan Levinson a question
for you from our control room from the
executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda what's your question dan what's
this been like for your family we've
heard reports your father was dead must
be a roller coaster yeah absolutely is
there are ups and downs we never lose
hope but of course it's it can be
discouraging I would say the events of
this past week given the the 25 million
dollar total reward the Iranian response
president Trump's tweet they've all been
encouraging and significant developments
and we're hoping that they don't lead to
increased communications between our two
governments to resolve this case and get
him home dan what's been the response in
the Trump administration to your
father's flight they have been very
dedicated and we've worked very closely
with Robert O'Brien who was the formerly
he was the special envoy for hostage
affairs now the National Security
Advisor and he's very concerned about
the case and he's in touch with us
regularly secretary Pompeo has been
wonderful because he has taken an
interest long before he was in his roles
now so they've been very responsive we
think that their increased pressure on
Iran is going to be helpful for us as
well do you see a possible diplomatic
solution to this given the relationship
between the two countries now it was so
bad yeah we're hopeful I think it's only
gonna it's gonna come down to something
between the two governments as well
we've always been told and I think we
work with all kinds of actors within
this environment but I think it's going
to come down to the u.s. and Iran
talking about it and making some sort of
deal barriers you know there are all
sorts of people that go out there and
try to sell information they can be
hustlers and you know really bad people
right they take advantage of people like
the Levinson family well I mean you know
I you know in the book you kind of
follow this retinue of people who are
going out there trying to find
information trying to get money to find
information in the last few years more
of them have stepped forward you know I
have only one hope and that's for for
the Levinson family
for Bob's wife for Bob's children for
his grandchildren for everyone involved
and that is that there is someone out
there forget about these governments but
there is an individual out there who
will be tempted by the money put on the
table to come forward tell the truth let
this family know what has happened and
if Bob is alive how he can be brought
home this has been a terrible story it's
been a tragedy and and to allow this
tragedy continue is just awful and it's
pointless it serves no point and then
final question for you 30 seconds or so
what's the next step for your family
well we're gonna continue to press this
case we have a lawsuit against Iran in
Washington that starts next month the
trial we're gonna work with the US
government we're gonna work with
the Trump administration and make sure
that he's not forgotten we have a lot
that we can work with now and we're
gonna junior press the Iranians we're
not going away and they have to know
that well Dan Levinson thank you very
much for being with us
Mary Mayer thank you also for being here
my pleasure Petronius and come back any
time to keep us all posted on the search
for a man who put his life on the line
for his country next up the spy games
the private companies hired to spy on
human rights activists journalists and
political opponents when we reach her
back now with an update on our reporting
about the spy games the secretive world
of private intelligence companies who
have been caught red-handed going after
journalists political opponents and
human rights advocates one watchdog
group called citizen lab is out with a
new report this week on how one such
group was hacking into the phones of its
targets around the world it's something
by the way that citizen lab knows a lot
about especially after they themselves
became the target of corporate spies the
setting was a five-star hotel of New
York City the host for lunch a man using
the name of Michael Lambert the target
was John Scott R Elton the head of the
citizen lab at the University of Toronto
a watchdog group which has been
investigating how the Saudi government
and others have been cracking down on
dissidents but Railton knew something
was fishy about this meeting someone was
trying to spy at his group and he
invited reporters from The Associated
Press to watch as he tried to turn the
tables I don't have this pretty well
actually I think you'll want to because
was visiting with your company this
morning
and you know it's very strange she says
it doesn't exist the man refused to say
who he really works seems like a while
ago now that you know were last speaking
about Tango in New York being followed
around my punches looks for hire and yet
you have continued your own
investigation into this Wild West world
of private intelligence gathering
that's exactly right well I think you
know if you want to get the attention of
an investigator or a journalist target
them directly and they'll get very
interested in you pretty quickly and
what have you discovered in your latest
episode so the most recent work that
we've actually been doing involves work
by getting my colleagues at the citizen
lab tracking the proliferation of NSO's
technology NSO is an Israeli based
company it sells technologies for
remotely hacking mobile phones and back
in May there was a public announcement
that was am the technology messaging
company owned by Facebook had been used
to deliver spyware to a large number of
individuals phones since that time we
worked with whatsapp and with some data
from whatsapp to try to understand who
those victims were who the targets were
of this hacking it was recently hi my
name is Jose
well whatsapp announced that there were
about 1,400 individuals whose mobile
phones have been targeted with this
technology and based on research done by
myself and my colleagues at citizen lab
we estimate that at least a hundred of
them are pretty clearly no less human
rights defenders and others but that
number has been growing since the public
announcement and the spine was done on
behalf of whom well this is a great
question
so NSO group the company that
manufactures this technology and
distributes it says you know what we
sell the government's what they do with
it is really their business what Sam
however didn't just announce that this
happened they actually have taken NSO to
court in California and their lawsuit is
really interesting part of what's
interesting about that lawsuit is that
it Pierce's
the bubble that NSO had created which
said well we don't really know how our
technology is being used when whatsapp's
lawful lawsuit lays out is that it
appears that Penna so is directly
involved in the use of its technology
and so we know a lot more about how that
technology is being used and abused in a
statement about the lawsuit the NSL
group said in the strongest possible
terms we dispute the allegations and
will vigorously fight them our
technology is not designed or licensed
for use against human rights activists
and journalists it has helped to save
thousands of lives over recent years
what do you say to that what we see is
that that narrative gets trotted out
again and again in the face of a
mountain of evidence that there are
clear-cut cases of abuse journalists
human rights defenders family members
members of opposition political groups
not only occasionally targeted but
pretty much always targeted when a
government gets their hands on this
technology this is a civil lawsuit that
fell but isn't there a crime here well
that's a great question and it certainly
appears that there may be criminal
investigations ongoing as well have you
been contacted by the FBI Susan I can't
comment on investigative things that
have not yet been made I think that the
problem comes down to this at the end of
the day there is an industry value in
the billions that spends every day
trying to find ways to access our mobile
phones whether it's through chat apps or
whether it's through some other
vulnerability that we don't yet know
about well John thank you very much and
keep up the good work the interesting
you talked to you in the months to come
about what is the latest in this case
absolutely and with pleasure I always
bring my shirts up next our shoutout for
the man who quietly helped to make
possible some amazing investigative
journalism in America's Appalachia
region
and our shoutout tonight for one of the
great champions of investigative
journalism Tom Galloway who passed away
earlier this year a prominent lawyer he
quietly help to support journalists
around the world who were committed to
taking truth to power especially in his
beloved Appalachia where he grew up poor
never forgetting those who remain
trapped in a place where powerful
interests oppress and abuse it was a
project that no 1 news organization had
been able to take on a sweeping
indictment of how and why so many people
in America's Appalachian region had no
safe reliable source of clean drinking
water reporters from three different
outlets came together for the project
from the Charleston Gazette nail my name
is Katie Coyne I'm a reporter at the
Charleston Gazette now West Virginia
Public Broadcasting I'm Molly Bourne I
work with West Virginia Public
Broadcasting and the elections and
herald-leader my name is Will Wright I
work for the Lexington herald-leader
this project especially dives into
things that affect people's daily life
you know access to water it's something
that many people don't even think about
spending months traveling across West
Virginia and Kentucky water should be
clear and odors
[Music]
and that's
something we don't have you and have for
a very long time if you turn on your tab
and it's white and it smells like
flooring
you know that's not good he was a
journalistic tour de force all made
possible by one wealthy lawyer whose
only credit was a short screen credit at
the end of the video embellishing the
Ganaway Foundation chaired by Tom
Galloway who died earlier this year I
think he really understood poverty I
think he understood some of the really
intense struggles that happen in places
like where he grew up in Appalachia and
he had a very deep sense of wanting to
give back Shawnee Senate runs the ground
truth project that spearheaded the water
investigation Tom understood the power
of journalism from his very earliest
days as a lawyer where he took on big
coal and really went after some of the
companies that were really destroying
the environment and treating people very
unfairly in the communities they were
they were based as a successful lawyer
Galloway was later involved in going
after the misty's at the corrupt energy
company Enron he funded projects about
human rights and LGBT rights in Africa
he followed up on the reporting that
Rhonda Schwartz and I did at ABC News
above the treatment of garment factory
workers in sweatshops in the American
territory of the Northern Marianas
locked fire exits overheated electrical
panels toilets that don't work what
authorities called flagrant violations
of US labor and safety laws part of a
legal team that later got a 20 million
dollar settlement for some 30,000
workers but Galloway's passion was for
Appalachia where he grew up in poverty
and then first emerged as a lawyer
speaking up for the little guy dedicated
his entire career to trying to help
those people who are underserved telling
their story became part of that work
journalism became a critical appendage
to all of the legal work that he did in
a way that could tell a story that he
wouldn't necessarily be able to tell in
the courtroom
Galloway's becky has already helped to
fund major investigations at West
Virginia's leading newspaper The Gazette
mail at a time the paper was in
financial straits
according to reporter Ken Ward Tom
Galloway's legacy for Appalachia is not
just all the litigation he did to bring
bad guys to justice but it's the
journalism that's going to live on for
years and years and years giving people
the kind of information they need about
their community we have two reporters in
our newsroom now that are funded by them
and at a time when advertising revenues
are dropping and it's difficult to keep
staff up that kind of those kind of
resources two additional reporters one
of them dedicated to covering southern
West Virginian the other one dedicated
to covering poverty issues in southern
West Virginia Galloway was once named
trial lawyer of the Year by a group
called public justice and he lived in a
life of luxury with grand homes in
Colorado Washington DC and Martha's
Vineyard but his wife Kathy says he
would have traded it all to be one of
those investigative reporters he admired
so much I think he was so enamored of
the work that you were able to do Brian
and Rhonda he would you would have given
his left pinky to be able to have
hospitality you had a journalism you
still drink your tap water or is this
solely what you drink not really why not
the water project from ground truth came
as Galloway knew his days might be
numbered and he died know there were
Galloway fellows across Appalachia and
elsewhere doing the work he's so admired
he dreams of having a strong
investigative journalism unit in every
newspaper and
radio station across America he was a
brilliant storyteller and he would like
to see the most brilliant storytellers
telling the public what's happening in
their communities across the country but
that would that would be a wish come
true for him
Tom Galloway was a strong supporter and
a good friend to me and our executive
producer Rhonda Schwarz and to so many
journalists around the world he will be
missed but as legacy will continue to
the Galloway foundation in the able
hands of his wife Cathy and daughter
Erin that's our program for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you right back here next week on the law
and crime Network